[Music]
thank you
welcome to the data science hangout hope
you're all having a great week
I'm Rachel Dempsey if you haven't had a
chance to meet yet I lead our Pro
community at posit
and so the data science hangout if
you've never been before is our open
space to chat about data Science
Leadership questions you're facing and
getting to hear about what's going on in
the world of data across different
Industries and so it happens every
Thursday at the same exact time same
place so if you're watching this
recording sometime in the future on
YouTube later the link to add it to your
calendar will be in the details below
and we'd love to have you join us live
too
together we're all dedicated to making
this hangout a welcoming environment for
everybody and so we love hearing from
everyone no matter your level of
experience or area of work
it's totally okay to just listen in here
and
there's always three ways you can jump
in and ask questions or provide your own
perspective too so you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to put like a little star
next to it if you want me to read it
instead if you're in a coffee shop or
kids are running around or whatever is
going to be going on
um and then third we also have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously
and I see Hannah just shared that in the
chat right now so thanks Hannah
I will say Emily I have wanted you to
join us here for so long and we've also
had a number of requests to have you on
so I'm so excited to have you here with
us today Emily is senior manager a
customer management data science and
analytics at Capital One now Emily let's
maybe get started by just having you
introduce a little bit about your role
and what you do and maybe something you
like to do outside of work too
yeah definitely
and thank you so much Rachel like
thrilled to be here have like benefited
so much like listening in watching
videos from all these conversations and
I'm really excited to take part today
so um I've been at Capital One for about
the past seven years over that time I've
held a number of different roles but um
fortunately both um
the data science toolbox and
specifically R has really been like a
through line for me throughout whatever
I've been doing
spent some time on in the more strategic
analytical analytics and modeling spaces
solving kind of very specific business
problems related to our card business
um I'd say overall I think my careers
pulled me kind of like progressively
further and further up the data stack is
no matter what problem Downstream I'm
really motivated by solving
I always realize there's some roadblock
just one level higher and I get really
excited about like well how do I just
solve that one pain point in that one
so um after starting out more in that
life
for slime data science space moved a
little bit through their Upstream when I
got really passionate about inner Source
tool tooling and bringing the best of
what I saw from the outside
um our community into my company and
building internal packages to help us
solve common business problems like
customer lifetime value modeling setting
and forecasting kpis and even connecting
to just different Enterprise systems
and um really enjoyed kind of like
building out both um those packages but
also
um really figuring out that you needed
to also build out
an inner Source Community around them
um again copying so much from what I've
learned from
#our stats Twitter
and um
been kind of
continuing that trajectory Upstream
moved more and more progressively into
also adding in elements of analytics
engineering and data engineering to
tackle
um kind of standardizing harmonizing
breaking silos in that raw data input
that would then flow through the tools
of the ultimate data products
so um
that's kind of
my trajectory and where I've where I've
landed today awesome and what's
something you like to do outside of work
too
uh big big Runner and big reader so
nice we'll have to ask you about some
favorite books that later on too
um but I I love that you just started
off with talking about inner Source
there and that's something that actually
came up on a hangout maybe that was last
year was Zach Garland at MasterCard and
I'm curious for all of us here too like
what is inner Source really mean and can
you explain a bit about what that
Community looks like at Capital One yeah
definitely
so
in some ways it's it's almost a funny
thing to explain because I think to the
open source Community it sounds so
natural it almost looks like why does
this concept require its own name but I
think sometimes like in large
corporations you're just in different
environments you don't just have that
nice Synergy where
someone sitting halfway in the world as
you has happened to already solve your
problem and put the answer up on GitHub
um and so there can be a lot of I think
redundant work both in one person's
project like moving from Project to
project or different teams something
like very similar problems maybe like
sometimes Reinventing the wheel on even
the framework or solving that problems
other times like using the exact same
framework but like rewriting the same
boilers like codes like for hyper
parameter tuning or something like that
so intersource is just really the idea
of
kind of both building kind of tools in
an internal code base that multiple
teams can contribute to over time
and um
as I mentioned like that only also works
if you like try to build up that same
sort of
community and enthusiasm and inclusivity
and knowledge sharing around it to
support it
and so that's with like a lot of the
internal packages that you create too
yeah definitely so yeah a lot of um
I think you can like think about it the
definition pretty extensively you know I
mean being anything from
you know I mean like there's so many
opportunities I think to standardize
across the data stack but I think the
place I've definitely focused on it most
is in the art package space
I love that so
so hopefully like it one package for one
thing and then everybody around across
Capital One is using it for that
yeah that that's always been
like been the goal and I think the other
really cool thing about that is um
really digging into like the levels of
abstraction and that like
not like you obviously never want to
constrict different teams from like
solving problems in different ways
because different parts of the business
inherently should be customizing and
tailoring but it becomes a really fun
problem thinking you know what should be
standardized like not everyone wants
stripe the glue code to like connect to
database and get through your proxy
but where are the right degrees of
freedom of like
what optimization method might be truly
better for one type of problem than
another
and then um
it also kind of I think helps you
aggregate those business use cases and
create that kind of um body of knowledge
of like this these are how different
teams like have solved this different
problems why they needed to like layer
in different tools and like it becomes
kind of a knowledge store for I think
for some of the complexity of Any Given
problem
I'm always really interested in
um like how you can standardize across
standardize things but also share new
packages or share ways of doing things
across such a huge company too
yeah no I mean I think definitely
is as best you can I think like a lot of
companies do use like a version control
system like get lab or GitHub so like
obviously First Step minimum bar is just
like getting it out there but I think
there's there's a great little O'Reilly
book on in your source that um one of
the chapter headlines is literally like
just because you use GitHub doesn't mean
you're doing inner source which I think
is um really critical that like I think
in open source we are sometimes spoiled
by the extent to which it is um if you
build it they will come
they will not always come internally I
think like corporate incentives are
different
um sometimes the culture people just
have no expectation that if they look
they might find something
so I think definitely
there's a little bit more of shoe
leather beat the pavement in terms of
talking to other teams trying to present
it to internal forums
but um also again building up that
Community with things like
I leaned very heavily on like slack
channels to kind of like bootstrap and
internal version of like Twitter to um
try to get those just like
serendipitous Asic conversations gone
yeah definitely Libby I see you had
asked something in the chat a bit
earlier do you want to jump in
sure yeah I was wondering if you could
describe in general terms without giving
a bunch of details that you can't give
um maybe some of the projects or the
problems that you are working on solving
with your team right now
yeah definitely so I think
pretty wide
um
range of things and I'm trying to like
figure out how to answer that to be like
perfectly honest at like the right level
of abstraction but
um
I think
something that's really been top of mind
for me lately is just like
how you can really shape that kind of
like raw data layer and make it like the
most usable for kind of like the last
mile analysis
so um one broad area of interests that
I'll say has been really on my mind is
thinking about how to structure raw data
into like really meaningful
um you could almost call it like a
metric smarter feature Mart although
it's not quite the same thing but just
like how you can embed kind of like more
custom like contexts about a business
problem in individual data elements to
have like more of those off the shelter
use kind of across
you know metrics tracking across like
modeling and kind of like future
engineering
um some of the like business areas that
I'm most focused on these days in our um
card space is our um kind of like credit
line select practice strategies to help
um
be sure very like
you know like equipping our customers to
like
have the best kind of both like
Financial Health but ability to like
pursue their interests
thank you I'm starting to see a lot of
questions uh over in the chat too and
Mike I swear I did not see your question
there when I asked that so maybe I'm
starting to think like a data science
leader a little bit more here but Mike
did you have any
um follow-up questions or anything else
you want to get out of um
like communicating in our source
packages and best practices yeah thanks
I mean I I first of all it's great
having Emily on on this data science
hangout I've been following your blog
post for ages and they're really
inspirational so please keep doing those
um the question was really about what I
see a lot is that
um when you send out an email or send a
message on teams or have a community
meeting maybe you only get 20 of the
whole population of people you're trying
to Target at that one thing and you know
there's value in spamming people across
many platforms but I also know that many
of the people that I want to try and
target with here's a best practice or
I've written this document or here's a
package you might be interested in some
of them have already kind of muted that
Channel or you know a email rule that
just you know I'll talk that straight
into this folder so how do you kind of
gradually increment the number of people
who see those messages
yeah I mean I think
definitely the like
in an Enterprise setting I think I have
also learned more also on those like
personal relationships to get the word
out than you would necessarily um in the
open source context
so both in terms of
I think kind of like leaning on
leadership to like help identify people
that may be working on similar projects
or patterns kind of throughout the
company or ideally I think having a
forum where you're intended to kind of
like
share updates not on an individual
project because it's like how do you get
people to come to that Forum initially
but if you can get people interested in
the idea of like technical knowledge
sharing at a higher level
aggregating kind of like
many types of information in that one
space I mean again to like make an open
source analogy back like kind of like
internal or open side analog or internal
like our weekly type newsletter I think
it can be easier to like
sell and socialize
the
the broader concept than maybe an
individual like artifact thereof
yeah thanks
thank you Marley and I see you had a
question in the chat do you want to jump
in here
yeah sure um hey Emily by the way great
uh presentation at signicomp that was
where I first got to see you so that was
fantastic
um and my question was uh what do you do
in your job that you didn't actually
anticipate seeing yourself doing like I
think we all kind of get blindsided by
this weird like Niche skill or task and
we're like I didn't sign up for this
right but I was just curious because
you've been with Capital One for a bit
um do you have anything like that you
could share oh my God like I if anything
I feel like that's truly the story of
and to your point like
I don't think I'm unique in this regard
but I think um
does almost feel like it summarizes my
career Arc went from like math to
statistics because I wanted to like math
through the real world but then found
like the shift from like deductive
deductive reasoning like not at all like
math Ben went from stats to data science
because I wanted to like
use the statistical toolbox to you know
like solve these like beautiful
probabilistic type problems but then
found like all of my challenges were
more into like date and tooling layer
and so you I mean I think it's a
this may be a kind of generic answer but
I think like being obsessed with like
not only like data quality but even
Upstream of that like how is data
getting collected how do Source systems
work that are processing the customer
records that are then spitting out the
data I think like I definitely never
expected myself to like
keep going like further upstream and
further back into more of the like
technical stack
as opposed to like proving a nice little
theorem which is where I started out but
I think um
definitely something where I think a lot
of my mind share goes but that I find is
like super helpful for the last mile
because even if you know some like
really weird perk in your system of like
oh we were never able to like
email these customers for extra reasons
it's like suddenly then you also know
like population that like something
happened to you for a
systemic reason
it could feel some like really
interesting and now
so I think the both going Upstream but
then being able to like round trip back
Downstream are probably two things that
I never would have anticipated
yeah cool it's funny you share that um I
recently was told that data science were
snobs like we're only happy with the the
tail end of the data stream
um I quickly had to kind of like snap my
head around and say well I think we're
if anything more holistically we're
interested in the holistic health of
data like from start to finish literally
nurturing it from its Inception all the
way to the end
um but I found that really interesting
so it's funny that you're reiterating
that that you you find yourself looking
Downstream just as much as you are
upstream and where you're at so anyway
thanks for sharing I'll shut up now not
at all and yeah I love that um
I mean to me I think that's also part of
what really puts to like science and
data science since um
seeing the whole system I forget someone
in in the more ecology side of our stats
Twitter once commented on something I
wrote about like
oh like the data generating process like
I have all these same concerns as you do
it's just for me it's when I fell out of
the boat and I drop my notepad and it's
like
very different like cause missing data
but
potentially similar outcome
I love that putting the science in data
science
Alan I see you had a question in the
chat too want to jump in next yeah sure
hi Emily um I I'm really curious to
learn a little bit more about where your
team fits down like in if there's a
bigger analytics organization in which
you fit and do you have peers who are
similar leaders of like analytics within
other functions and teams and if you
collaborate and and what that
expectation is or if your focus is
mostly kind of inward to to your team
and I know it's probably a mix of all of
the above I'm just I'm really curious
and sort of like how your team fits in
the rest of an organization that it I
imagine is really big yeah no and I'll
definitely again like
um
dance around that potentially a tiny bit
just um to not
talk too too much about Capital One
specifics but like yes super large
organization very Matrix so and like
I've always sat kind of like within a
specific line of business and
um been predominantly focused on solving
that businesses problems I was
um pretty lucky to have like super
supportive leadership I think early on
and continuing throughout my career that
um
really kind of like latched on to like a
lot of these same ideas of obstruction
and scale and was willing to kind of
like support building out a team that
honestly is like a little bit more
um
kind of like business facing and
interdisciplinary skill sets than would
usually even be tackling some of these
problems versus kind of like a pure Tech
Team or a data engineering team or
breaking all those pieces up
but um yeah we definitely have a lot of
great kind of I think
analogs throughout the business that
have their team structured
really in many different ways you know
like the mix of Staffing whether it be
more business focused people or
engineering Focus people whether it be
like centralized or Federated
and um
it can definitely be complex navigating
really large organ that way but I think
it does like
help bring a lot of interesting ideas to
the table when you have like
different types of people in different
like organ configurations
while trying to like tackle problems
bring the best spare of their own tool
back
for sure yeah and your journey sounds
like has been one of building that
really focused team in part
yeah definitely and I think
the based on kind of I think the biggest
bet that the people that were maybe
I mean like me starting out a little bit
more Downstream maybe not the best state
like not the best engineer by mile that
you could like
put on that work
that kind of like finding people that
can like Bridge those multiple worlds
and kind of like pull that Downstream
context Upstream
um
I think it's maybe not
not what I'd say is the overaching
Norm but I think it's like definitely a
pattern that is um
things like the good traction
cool thank you
thank you
I see Javier is calling out your amazing
book collection behind you and so Javier
said it looks like data science book
Heaven do you have a favorite book
behind you oh my goodness that would be
a hard one to pick and we could use the
rest of the hour
um going through those
um one of my weirdest or like strangest
like post-pandemic Hobbies has been had
the opportunity to review a ton of books
for um kind of CRC press and then as
consequence have um kind of built out my
library with a lot of those
um I think off the top of my mind like
obviously like the galleries through
thinking statistics I think I know it's
a little bit of a generic recommendation
but if um
I think can just be like
such a lovely like whether or not your
patient or frequent test like won't get
controversial here but it's just such a
like um
beautiful probabilistic approach to
thinking about data and modeling
um
I'm very into I have a lot of um
epidemiology books just because I um
like never was really in the Health
Sciences field myself but I've found
those to actually be some of the most
informative strangely for um business
use because I think stacked books often
talk about things from the standpoint of
like assume you have this perfectly
clean data it's in this Matrix called X
now we'll prove some nice theorems
where's Epi books almost start more with
like fifth floor on fire we want to
figure something out we don't have any
of the data we want their biases
everywhere what do we do give it back
and I think
you know like again when you're just
trying to work with a lot of larger
observational data in an org setting
that just like super pragmatic
what can I do with what I have available
is um pretty cool but um again could
like definitely um
pass along a lot more specific wrecks um
based on the category
what was the the title the first one you
recommended
uh I may have said it wrong I think it's
actually statistically what you're
thinking okay if anybody wants to share
the link to that in the chat that would
be super helpful too
uh but Emily somebody something I wanted
to ask you is I know so many people here
in our hangout room have benefited from
your blogs and conference talks and so
much more and
um I was just wondering like for you
what have been some of the benefits of
contributing to the open source
community
oh my goodness so like so very many I
think first and foremost obviously is
just like all of the amazing like
relationships you form people you get to
meet and being a fly on the wall of like
conversations that like
I'd never get to hear like Epi
professors talk or biostats professors
talk the Recon professors talk in my
day-to-day life but just being able to
continue to like
pull and I think this is especially
unique to R from all these like really
rich interdisciplinary communities and
steal the best ideas and then taking
back to my day job and then I look like
I like came up with a new idea and I
didn't I'm just stealing like an artist
um so I think that's the people is
definitely a huge benefit
in terms of like contributions I think
something that I found
a very surprising benefit
is the way that it's made me have to
think
a lot more critically and a lot more
formally about what I was doing anyway
and otherwise I think even as I've um
kind of dodged a couple of questions
here today of like oh can I like
how much detail can I go into here the
upside of that is I think a lot of the
things that I found
that I can like
really lean in to talk about
um
it forces me to like think about the
problems that I'm facing at that higher
level of abstraction and think about
like what have I learned from this
that's not just true to my last project
but just due to my next project and
history to other people's projects
so I think um
it's definitely a fun intellectual
challenge I think
almost like taking a final exam in
school to kind of like force you to
formalize your own knowledge
that's really interesting yeah so like
by not being able to give some of the
specifics you're able to then like take
a step back and look at this big picture
so you can then help other people too
think a little bit more in terms of
those like core patterns
definitely
um I see uh apologies if I mispronounce
your name I'm not sure if your first and
last are connected there but he uh Heba
bukhari you had a question into the chat
do you want to jump in
for Rachel
um that was that was cool to know
yeah hi Emily uh very nice to meet you
um and yeah great talk I love your blog
and I was wondering someone for someone
who's making the transition into the
data science world and trying to build
her portfolio and her skills
I think
from what I'm seeing is more important
than the experience
is showing off the skills and and
showing off the personal brand so what
advice would you have for someone who is
like I'm still building my blog I'm
still trying to to
create stuff to be able to put them out
there
um what advice would you have for me or
someone like me
yeah no great great question and I think
I'm trying to remember I think it was
back in like 2018 or 2017 it's been a
while but um David Robinson gave an
amazing talk at our studio comp about
this that's probably floating around in
a video somewhere but I know I
personally found really empowering I
think kind of like the first and
foremost advice
I think it's like
get it out there like anything that's
out in the world I think was really the
the stock is better I mean than anything
that's on your hard drive and I think
that you know like Canon times be
intimidating but I think
um
a
I think like a lot of work can be like a
lot more
impressive and interesting to the
outside world and sometimes we even
believe when we've been like mild deep
working on it for so long
and also especially in a great Community
like the our stats Community I feel like
people are really supportive that like
yeah they might have some advice
throughout their ideas so maybe they
leave a comment but everyone does it in
such a genuinely nice way like if
anything sometimes I like
crave for somebody to like comment on
something that I wrote and be like no
you're wrong and here's 10 reasons why
because I think that'd be a really
interesting discussion but I think like
a definitely don't be intimidated to get
stuff out there
and then I think
second like kind of like key thing
is um
again like
finding projects that you're like
genuinely interested in and passionate
by you know I think a lot of people like
there's decreasing marginal returns from
like an employer's perspective seeing
someone else play with like the Titanic
data set whereas like I think you'll
both showcase your own skills better
as well as kind of like really engage
your audience
if you just like kind of chase after
some passion and find something like a
little bit new and different to bring to
the table
thank you
um I
I think I miss one of your questions
from earlier Travis and just want to
have you jump in here
sorry about that I think that movie was
a while ago yeah no it's fine hey I'm
like sorry to break your level of
abstraction um that you've built up here
but uh I I wanted to ask a bit about DBT
um I know we talked about this a couple
years ago yeah I wonder how that's
evolved for you
um are you using it still these days
have you integrated more with our you
have the DVT player package which I see
um like kind of is just hanging out
there
um trying to generate interest across
the across our community like you know I
mean it's a really cool complementary
tool but um not a lot of Integrations
yet as far as I can tell
how's it going for you yeah no I'm still
and like maybe I'll just take a step
back and like explain for a minute like
kind of what DBT is through those that
aren't familiar
um DBT is a framework for building data
pipelines in SQL and what it kind of
nuts you is a lot of the same benefits
that I think we all value with like
reproducibility in R which tends to be
harder with databases and with um DBT so
you can do things like um
devtrad deployments you can do better
testing it helps you modulize your code
better so you can you know have um
easier Version Control these are your
code reviews and
um it just end with um some ginger
templating it makes SQL more like a
higher level
um kind of programming language with a
legitimate control flow
um definitely if you work in on
databases I'd recommend checking it out
because I think there's like a lot of
spiritual similarity with um
just things this community like tends to
value and get excited by
um I continue to be a like kind of big
fan of Beats and both tools I'd have to
say I've never really found that sweet
spot of exactly learn how to integrate
them
I think um
still tend to have like
DVT pipelines trending more in the
database player but kind of switching
more into our mode for real um
okay obviously like kind of analysis
reporting modeling Etc
um
I've always felt like there ought to be
some like linkage especially with
something like DB flyer but um
haven't like
have not gone there yet and would be
like fascinated if anyone else has like
played with both and had funny any takes
there
yeah likewise in all your spare time
right
um and I'm sure everyone else is in the
in the same space but yeah my experience
has been the same yeah I feel like when
I'm in DBT I'm in straight SQL world and
there's no direct linkage but um
mirroring your thoughts on the spiritual
similarity the the community there is
really really good and
um yeah it's it's a good tool yeah and
the minimum it's like it helps kind of
like keep your mind in the same place
even if like
quite that like deep deep integration
yeah thanks sounds like this would be a
good part to share with the Tidy verse
team too
yeah let's
um
so I see uh so I just want to remind
everybody if you joined a little bit
later that you can ask questions a few
different ways so there's a slido link
if you want to ask anything anonymously
you can always raise your hand here on
Zoom or you can continue putting
questions into the zoom chat too
um and if you put a little star next to
it I'll know to to read it out loud
um but I see toyan had asked
um piggybacking on Libby and Marlene's
earlier questions what has kept you at
Capital One for seven years
that's a great question I know
especially in this day and age I think
it's like
the less common route to stay the like
single company for a long time I think
um
definitely like I think pros and cons to
it I think definitely the thing that's
kept me motivated is being able to like
continue to like expand my scope expand
my skill set both in terms of in such a
large company having um different areas
business to move around to which is so
I'm still kind of like thinking about
different like strategic issues
throughout my career somewhat similar to
like changing companies
as well as um
kind of growing out my technical skills
in different dimensions so I think um
I'm definitely somebody that like
it's very edgy if I don't feel
like I'm continuing to learn but I think
I've found ways that like
I really feel like I continue to be able
to do that in my career
and um
secondly this is very like silly reason
definitely not a career defining one but
um going back to intersource I will warn
you like packages are kind to like
children and there have been times in my
career even where I've been offered a
different role internally or something
and I've like been like oh but then I'd
have to like I don't know how to say
goodbye so
you aren't
thank you
Trevor I see you had a question in the
chat you want to jump in next
hi everyone good day
yeah so so I've been following this
space very carefully and I've been a
part of several discussions about the
impact that AI
is and will have on our profession
uh I must say I I'm just uncertain about
the future to be honest they
it's developed it's developing an
evolving so fast you know so I was just
trying to understand from your
perspective
what do you see how AI is actually
impacting your current workflow
and what's your your thoughts are in
terms of how it will impact a data
science based in the mid to well near to
Mid mid future
yeah no that is such an interesting
issue right now and I feel like
definitely um
I know a lot of very um
strongly opinionated like strong
opinions on both sides of the spectrum
of whether it's going to change
everything or nothing I think through
the
through the type of work I do and the
type of like kind of values
per se that I have about data science
I think they're like large parts of it
that I don't expect it to change a ton
or I almost hope it doesn't change a ton
um I and I'll give like a couple of
examples of that I know I'm like I think
even there are a lot of um companies and
tools right now that are working on like
automated NLP query generation which on
one hand like
seems really cool yeah I'd love to be
able to just answer anyone a question
ask a question and get an answer
but then there's like I think the the
data quality like part of my head like
like the fire alarm goes off that like
if like
there may be an AI That's like smart
enough to like write a sonnets far
sooner than there is one that's smart
enough to think
based on the kind of conditional
probability this person wanted should I
cast the nulls in this table to a zero
or should I leave them as zeros and what
should be in the denominator and you
know I mean I think if anything like
data quality and data bias will save us
because I think those are um so
sufficiently hard
for humans to ever be precise enough in
language about what they mean and
um
kind of like clear enough and
what the right result should be that um
I feel pretty confident that's going to
remain like solidly like human problem
for much longer time
and then similarly on The Last Mile like
I mentioned before I think I'm
very passionate about kind of like
thinking about
feature engineering curating like
both automated Solutions but also like
kind of understanding and bringing like
context into data science whether you
even think about cost sensitive loss
functions like model evaluation Beyond
traditional metrics
and I could imagine kind of like more
yes for shifting to those like for smile
and last miles of like
data quality and curation and
kind of rigorous business focused
evaluation but I definitely don't expect
their jobs to like go away because of AI
I understand what you're saying but
um even a lot of the processes that you
talk about we see AI
making its way into that space I
understand and I do totally agree with
your point about for example the feeling
of data right and an AI system may not
know the context
of what a missing value should be or why
are the other piece of data is the same
but it's but my thought process is a
little broader in the sense that for
example someone asked earlier
um what what you should think about
thinking about when you're entering the
data space as in if you're in school now
you're in maybe University
you're in the middle of doing uh a data
science degree
you know what will
um what will your future look like
um so we have seen for example in the
last maybe five to ten years past
um five years you have seen where like
data science is like the hottest topic
you know the hottest job right
um do we think that this
hot streak is going to continue into the
future or will this Art Street be
replaced by AI
if you understand what I'm asking
yeah definitely I mean at the end of the
day I think they're probably all just
Tools in a toolbox to solve the like
super wide range of problems like
I don't even know if like
data science will always be a career so
much as like data science is like
kind of an expectation of like
something professionals should be able
to apply to the problems they have at
hand like manipulating an Excel
spreadsheet
um and similarly with AI I think there
are probably some things like
um like in a legal setting like parsing
a ton of documents generating some
hypotheses like helping maybe structure
a preliminary Screen through like
legal Discovery or something like I
think there's some kind of assistive
thing say I can help with
but I like I personally I think like
don't love the idea of a world where
it's ever like making the final
decisions so I think
plenty of space at the table for
for both
yeah okay definitely okay all right
thanks
thank you I love that that perspective
on it and like thinking about how like
everybody knows how to use Excel right
now maybe at some point in the future
everybody will
know how to do some level of data
science
um I see Jonathan you had asked a
question on
uh there's a star so I'll read it but
it's data science involves tackling
complex problems what is your thought
process to solving a problem that you
don't know how to solve immediately and
what resources do you tap into that
assist you with problem solving
that's a really good question and it
really like printing question lately I
think for a couple of different reasons
I think the
one thing that I think is a really
undervalued part
of that process
is thinking about what is like how will
you know a good solution when you find
fun and how would you know if it was a
good solution if it was like staring you
in the face and you already had it I
think the more unstructured and
complicated
a problem can be
it can almost be a little deceptive of
what's what's good which can have like
one or two kind of like bad outcomes of
either
um
you find a good solution but you don't
realize it's good so you keep going or
you spend a lot of time like chasing
after an outcome and then you get there
and only then do you realize like
I solved the problem I was trying to
stop it was not the problem I wanted to
solve
so um something I've really been
experimenting with in my own work is
having a lot more of an explicit like
design stage at the beginning of a
project and thinking like how can you do
a pilot how can you like you know if I'm
trying to predict some Target
can I take those like True Values of
that Target and plug them into a
downstream problem I like actually
thought that was going to solve and make
sure that's actually what I want to
solve and almost kind of like
front loading model evaluation
with a even like fake solution is like
the first step for the last step
and then um I'll check on one other
point and sorry I'm kind of trampling
here but I think the other aspect of
that just again going back to that
levels of abstraction is figuring out
how to take the context out of my
problem to make it something more Google
so you know I mean thinking like like
not being like
oh this experiment the random seeds were
wrong so I don't have a control
population what do I do but then like
backing that into more of a general like
how do you sample a synthetic control
through observational data which is
something you can Google and then find a
ton of resources about so I think um
pushing myself on what I want and then
finding the right
brain which tasks for help
yeah
that's great thank you
honestly I see you had a question do you
want to jump in here next sure uh so
Emily I'm sure you've been in this
position before but any tips and advice
on communicating to non-technical
stakeholders or Android leadership
yeah no that's always the hot like
enduring Hot Topic and for very very
good reasons
I think like a couple of different I
think approaches that I tend to use
there
is a like leading with the solution
versus kind of like leading with the
solution and leading with Impact versus
leading with that like kind of process
and I think as many people know I'm the
like huge homework down fan and or maybe
now I should say quarto but I've
actually like come to the realization
but I kind of need to even change my
workflow for working with a tool like
that because like inherently like an uh
our Mark downward flow is kind of very
linear of like
I cleaned my data I did the analysis I
got the outcome but then from a
storytelling perspective
I think you can really like get the hook
and get the buy-in to like keep that
conversation going if you lead more with
the outcome of like
this is why what I'm about to tell you
is important
and then
some people want to really dig deeper
and understand the mechanics
some people won't and I think it's also
is like data person
um
learning to accept it that's okay that
they don't they don't want like like I
think all of us it's fair like it can
really be about the journey versus the
outcome but accepting for like leaders
reasonably that's often about the
outcome
but then um when I want to go into those
details I think I both either try to
like lean hopefully on
both and or either of like metaphors and
also like
diagrams or one really compelling plot
just anything to make it more
tangible versus like purely conceptual
okay
thank you very much I see uh Lewis you
had a similar question as well and do
you have any follow-up questions or did
that answer answer you as well
uh I guess maybe a follow-up and and
maybe it really is the same just clarify
I guess that one sense makes it sound uh
a communication kind of piece
but you have the same answer if it's a
brand new project or maybe a completely
different approach I don't mean a new
quantitative approach but maybe here's a
stakeholder who's not really worked with
quantitative people or maybe is wedded
to a tool set maybe they use a business
intelligence tool and you're advocating
shiny and it's interactive or something
like that so to them there's some kind
of context switch even if let's say
quantitatively there isn't do you have
any advice
uh on how to Advocate that and get the
buy and of course I imagine it's
probably still a question of here's why
what I'm about to tell you it should be
interesting or helpful but do you have
any anything else that's come up where
you say this has really worked when I'm
trying to Advocate something new yeah no
I think that's a great great point of
like
tools versus analyzes because like tools
are so inherently but kind of abstract
it can make it harder
but I do think
um
probably how I've like translated like
leaders inherently I think care a lot
about their the people on their team
hopefully from like the genuinely caring
perspective but at least from the like
managing capacity perspective like bare
minimum and I think kind of like leading
with the case I think of
I think most tools you can like also
bring a human Dimension into that story
you know whether it's like
it's such a pain point that people have
to like they're doing this manual work
every single month then that's like
inhibiting both them doing more
interesting projects in their career
development but there's a way to
automate this thing or like
hey thing you know three months ago like
we had this error and this breakdown of
this process and that's because
there aren't you know we don't have good
version control on GitHub and I think
always like
that you can tie it either to like
business outcomes or people outcomes
but I always I think try to Anchor more
to like
what is any tool do for you
um and there's a broader framework that
I like really like for thinking about
this called the jobs to be done
framework it kind of comes from the
project net product management world
and essentially like what that says is
like you can think about a tool as
someone you're like hiring to do a job
and like I'm kind of saying at a
trivially high level I think they're
they're smart at the actual Theory but
like I've always liked that um
kind of framework if you're like
thinking about the interview thinking
about like why should I like bother to
like hire an onboard you and is this
tool more like
almost going back to theater AI
discussion is this like an intern that I
only want to use with a very high level
of supervision or if you're thinking
about CI CD and process automation it's
like am I hiring an executive or a
contractor to just go run this process
for me
an abstracted way
and I I think that's like that framework
I think is really kind of
whether it's implicit or explicit hooked
kind of my like storytelling around
those technical tools also
pretty cool thank you thank you very
helpful
thank you
um so I see we have a few minutes left
here and I think still quite a few
questions here so I'm going to go and
try and go through some of these quickly
um but I see Bill had asked
um he said I'm in Pharma but wonder if
there are Trends blessed by management
to move away from some alternative
software which is how bill says SAS
um but maybe more broadly like
are there Trends from your leadership
like moving towards open source or do
you have free Reign Over the tools that
you get to use
I'm like definitely really lucky to be
an environment that's like pretty much
always been very very friendly to open
source
um and I think that is like I know a
trend I've seen across the industry I've
had the opportunity also to do some
Consulting projects with other people
more into biostats and Pharma Fields
um taking that leap to um
I'd copy those very diplomatic phrasing
if I could but um other proprietary
options to um to the r world
and especially I mean I can only imagine
I think the intersection of data tooling
with the current like economic
conditions I have to imagine can only
like kind of accelerate that Trend when
it's becoming an increasingly like easy
to hire skill set
much more attractive option through the
bottom line
and um
I think
that
gains that have been made in adoption in
both like Banking and finance as well as
like healthcare
um really put a lot more of a rubber
stamp of approval on
some version of Open Source and really
highly regulated Industries
thank you and amra I see you had a
question about transitioning into data
science roles do you want to jump in
here
yeah uh thank you and hi Emily
um yeah I so my like basic question was
that um I'm just transitioning into data
science Rules or I'm looking for data
science roles so I was just wondering
are there any considerations I should be
having
um while interview interviewing with
companies and
um uh in in terms of you know maximizing
my uh capacity to learn in that company
um because like I'll just give you some
more context I was just talking to one
of my friends who is in the healthcare
space and she was saying she's working
as a data scientist but then she was
saying that a lot of her time goes into
data processing rather than actually
having to being able to get any
influences out of data or being able to
do any kind of predictive
uh work so yeah I was just wondering
um
if there are any considerations I should
be having or if this is a non-question
I'm really not sure
yeah no I mean I think
there are three aspects I'd say to that
can be really helpful to understand like
a company's Tech stack when you're
interviewing and the amount of data they
have available that you don't want to be
like hired to be a data scientist and
then show up on day one and have them be
like
oh yeah here's the Google drive with
some csvs in it like go wild you know I
mean you want to be sure they have like
enough data to support analysis and that
either you'll be empowered to have the
tools to build out the data you need
yourself or maybe they also have like
data engineering or other job functions
secondly I think it's helpful to be
crisp about what you want to learn and
grow on in a role like data science can
be such a nebulous job title these days
you know I mean I think someplace like
it can mean anything from yeah
experimentation modeling machine
learning and I think um
really just clarifying your interests
and then just being able to like
articulate them like companies like do
not have any incentive to like hire you
for role you don't want so I think like
kind of being able to like share what
you're looking for
really just helps the matchmaking
but finally I think it's also really
good to recognize like you can learn a
ton in pretty much on you roll
and I think like
the spending a lot of time on data
processing
taking that just as an example
that is sometimes like the hard part the
complex part the part that like requires
actually still a lot of the data science
skill set of understanding how do I
shape this data
in a way that like
because I do understand the stats
because I do understand the algorithm
how do I like structure this problem in
a way that the algorithm can understand
and like at the end of the day I think
it's a funny conceit that
in school we spend most of our time
learning like hyper parameter tuning and
typing that like model.fit model dot
predict
that often isn't the hard part or
sometimes even like the most interesting
part so I think being open with a like
kind of growth mindset of like whatever
job you end up in there's going to be
like a ton to learn and a ton of really
interesting work to be done
uh thank you so I do understand that
it's more about uh the the company
having a good data culture and
um that way I think you will be able to
have more chances of maximizing your
learning yeah
for sure
it looks like always matters so much
yeah it looks like people had some uh
some other tips in the chat too like
Mike said a good question to ask is
maybe what does a data scientist do on a
typical day and Adam I thought this was
funny you said a tweet you saw that said
when you're interviewing for data
science roles ask whether you'll have
I.T or data Engineers if not
congratulations you're now both
foreign
I appreciate everybody sharing the links
and resources in the chat too
um I know we just got to the end of the
hour
here and I'm sorry if we didn't get to
answer everybody's questions we have one
minute if there's any other like
pressing question if somebody wants to
to raise their hand in here
Emily what is the best way for people to
stay in touch with you is it through
your website or LinkedIn or GitHub
honestly I think
wherever people are these days I'm still
um
like
for now I'm still on Twitter
um I'm still spending far more time
there than I should
um LinkedIn GitHub uh my website has my
contact information same with my email
like my handle on pretty much
and like at the
Fortune of having a like unusual enough
last name that my handling like LinkedIn
GitHub Twitter my Gmail everything's
Emily reader wherever so yeah please
like don't hesitate to get in touch I
awesome like I just uh love getting to
eat more of the community
oh sorry I think my internet was delayed
for a second but I just shared your
LinkedIn in the chat as well but um if
anybody has Emily's website handy or
blog and wants to share that there too
um but thank you so much Emily for
joining us today and for sharing your
your insights and experience with all of
us this was awesome oh thank you this
was a lot of fun
foreign